Megan Fox and Machine Gun Kelly were
spotted leaving a marriage counseling
office over the weekend following rumors
that the two called it quits but now a
source tells ET the two are trying to
mend things and move forward together
we've done every form of therapy that
exists
um we've found a therapist that really
works for us it's definitely a process
it's not an easy one some of some of
it's really difficult let's rewind
over the weekend rumors swirled that the
two split after Megan posted these pics
to Instagram alongside cryptic lyrics
from Beyonce's 2016 album lemonade quote
you can taste the dishonesty it's all
over your breath eagle-eyed fans were
quick to notice that Meg unfollowed her
fiancee and deleted all pics of him from
her page before deactivating her account
altogether a source at the time told E.T
that the two got into a big argument
before his performance at the Sports
Illustrated event on Saturday night in
Arizona leading up to the Super Bowl
quote Megan and MGK have a passionate
relationship filled with lots of intense
emotions both good and bad but after
this fight Megan was very upset
according to our source Meg was supposed
to come to the event but backed out last
minute and the argument affected the
musician's performance specifically he
wasn't in the right frame of mind to
take the stage following all that the
two were spotted leaving a marriage
counseling office in separate cars after
reportedly spending two and a half hours
inside now a source is explaining their
complicated Dynamic 2et Megan and MGK
have had ups and downs throughout their
relationship but at the end of the day
they have a lot of love for each other
and a deep connection The Source adds
that they have very strong feelings for
one another so their emotions often come
out in intense ways our therapist said
that a relationship is basically the
process of breaking each other down but
most people don't have the tools to
build each other back up to rebuild and
so it's a constant process of like
suffering and passion and love and the
repeat cycle so we're just learning that
and navigating that and doing that
together of course the two got engaged
back in January 2022.
and prior to the Super Bowl the pair
stepped out at the 2023 Grammys earlier
this month where the singer was a
first-time nominee I came in as a
hip-hop artist and I was nominated for
best rock album like already the
barriers were broken on what
what my limits were already supposed to
be set at and I broke through that and
I'm very happy and I'm very grateful
after he lost best rock album to Ozzy
Osbourne Megan praised her man on
Instagram for handling the process with
Grace and maturity
[Music]